so you want to see water freeze almost
immediately well here's what you're
going to need some very pure water fiji
water has been recommended to me by a
friend and obviously we're going to need
a freezer some way to cool it down so
i'm going to put this bottle of water in
the freezer in the area normally
occupied by the ice cube trays because i
think that might be the coldest part of
my freezer i've got two bottles just in
case one doesn't work and now we have to
wait there are lots and lots of videos
showing this phenomenon on youtube but
very few that explain how it actually
works so i'd like to take a minute and
do that water is normally a liquid at
room temperature because the water
molecules are all flowing past each
other tumbling around each other and
that allows the substance to flow when
something becomes solid its molecules
all more or less lock into place
they still vibrate where they're not
rolling over each other moving past each
other so they can no longer flow they're
solid now what we're doing here is
supercooling the water so we're taking
it below its temperature below zero
degrees where it will it should become
ice but it's very difficult for that
water to make the transition without
somewhere for that ice crystal to start
growing so what we need is some kind of
nucleation event if the water is not
pure the impurities in the water
naturally act as sites where the crystal
can start forming that's why it's very
important that we use very very pure
water another way we can cause this
nucleation event is to bang the water
bottle hopefully that will cause a few
water molecules to line up in the right
way and that will seed the rest of the
ice crystal so let's give it a few hours
and we'll come back and try to nucleate
this this ice forming event alright it's
taken a few days and multiple attempts
but I think this could finally be it I
might have finally created supercooled
water so let's let's find out I'm going
to take the water very carefully out of
the freezer
and now you can see clearly that the
water is still liquid you can see this
air bubble floating around and now I'm
going to bang it on the counter and we
will see if we can get an ice crystal to
form whoa look at that you can see that
ice crystal growing right down from the
top to the bottom so there you have it I
was finally able to demonstrate the
supercooled water phenomenon I cooled
down the very pure water in my freezer
for two or three hours and then by
banging the water bottle on the counter
I started the formation of an ice
crystal at the top of the bottle of
water which quickly grew down to the
bottom now performing this experiment
was a lot more difficult than I
anticipated
I did this at least eight times with
about five different bottles of water
and I only managed to catch it on tape
once so it was a real challenge things I
learned we're that you can't leave the
water in the freezer too long otherwise
it will freeze up on its own accord and
also you have to be very careful when
pulling the water out of the freezer
that you don't bump it because otherwise
it will start freezing right away before
you have a chance to bang it on the
counter so give it a try and see if you
can make it work